[Musica]
buongiorno
oggi vorrei parlarvi di tre cose
tre cose che ci sono generalmente a
cuore della felicità del successo che
del tempo mi sono spesso chiesto ma
bisogna avere successo per essere felici
o essere felici è una condizione
necessaria per avere successo
beh da piccolo era tutto abbastanza
chiaro io tutti quelli come tutti quelli
della mia generazione siamo cresciuti
con una frase che ci sentivamo spesso
ripetere prima il dovere e poi il
piacere non ci piaceva a me faceva
sbuffare però in qualche modo ci ha
aiutato a crescere più o meno
diligentemente poi con l'arrivare delle
prime responsabilità o inizialmente
rincorso il mito del work life balance
così ho cercato di trovare il giusto
equilibrio tra il tempo destinato al
lavoro e quello destinato alla vita
privata ma poi il mondo è diventato
improvvisamente iperconnesso e io mi
sono trovato impreparato nel gestire la
work life integration
in altre parole ho finito per perdere i
confini tra le pareti domestiche e
quelle dell'ufficio e quindi connesso
24 ore al giorno 7 giorni su 7
sfinito fisicamente mentalmente ho
capito che rincorrere tutto e tutti non
significa necessariamente raggiungere
dei risultati eccellenti
né tantomeno essere felici e la innata
cultura umana che ci porta a pensare che
per avere successo bisogna fare sempre
di più io penso invece che soprattutto
oggi bisogna fare di meno come
scegliendo
scegliendo come a chi dedicare la nostra
risorsa più preziosa
il nostro tempo il tempo è una vera
materia prima pregiata non si dona non
si trova in natura ci viene donata ogni
giorno si potrebbe dire che ne abbiamo
in abbondanza
e proprio questa abbondanza non ci fa
percepire tutta la bellezza del dono
per questo ci troviamo spesso a
trascorrere le nostre giornate
rincorrendo affannosamente arriviamo la
sera stanchi
con questo senso di affanno che prevale
sulla sensazione di avere contribuito
piacevolmente a qualcosa
a volte facciamo le ultime cose dopo
cena prima di andare a dormire
altre volte mettiamola sveglio un'ora
prima la mattina non dite che non
l'avete mai fatto ma tornando alla
necessità di scegliere fare meno se
provassimo a pensare quanto tempo in una
giornata
impieghiamo nel prendere decisioni
scopriremo che questa ne occupa la quasi
totalità
ogni giorno infatti decidiamo a che ora
svegliarci anche ora alzarci come
vestirci dove andare noi continuamente
decidiamo dove guardare ma avete mai
provato a pensare quanto tempo noi
dedichiamo ogni giorno nello scegliere a
cosa dedicare il nostro tempo
[Musica]
se state pensando se il tempo è così
prezioso perché li dedico così poco
tempo e di state immediatamente
chiedendo il perché beh dobbiamo
prendere atto che scegliere faticoso
infatti richiede uno sforzo cognitivo
che non è necessariamente associato ad
una sensazione di piacere e quindi ci
affidiamo a l'istinto che ci offre
l'interessante opportunità di scegliere
senza particolare sforzo che trascorrono
così le nostre giornate
ma se come diceva aristotele noi siamo
quello che facciamo ripetutamente allora
scegliere ripetutamente diventa
essenziale per il nostro successo è
anche per la nostra felicità
l'esperienza degli ultimi 15 anni che ho
fatto in goodyear una multinazionale
americana che sposa appieno i valori più
nobili del rispetto per per le persone
per il lavoro e che inevitabilmente
legata alle dinamiche del profitto
mi ha spinto ad approfondire proprio
questi collegamenti tra felicità e
successo frattempo investito e la
necessità di scegliere in effetti
prendere decisioni è il vero core
business di ogni imprenditore e manager
in azienda ad esempio per prendere delle
decisioni tra investimenti alternativi
generalmente calcoliamo il return on
investment roi una semplice formula
matematica che mette in relazione
l'utile atteso da un investimento con il
capitale che è necessario investire
mi sono allora chiesto è possibile
calcolare come impiegare al meglio il
nostro tempo
diciamo che queste riflessioni mi hanno
così ispirato il concetto del ritorno
con work horror come l'abbiamo chiamata
ne è nata così per analogia una
ipotetica formula matematica che vuole
calcolare come le risorse e le energie
il tempo che investiamo in ogni singola
attività o nella giornata di lavoro
contribuisce a quello che un po
l'obiettivo di tutte le aziende ossia la
crescita del business ormai da circa un
anno mi sono trasferito in medio oriente
a dubai in particolare con sempre con
goodyear dove i mercati sono
tendenzialmente in crescita crisi del
petrolio a parte ma ho trascorso tutti
gli ultimi anni di profonda recessione
in sud europa in portogallo in francia
in spagna e anche l'italia con la
necessità di accrescere il valore del
business
i mercati che non crescevano con margini
in generalizzata contrazione e quindi
con la necessità di ridurre costi di
tagliare di fare ristrutturazioni
inizialmente insieme al mio team abbiamo
provato a cercare modalità alternative
per fare di più per crescere il valore
del business con minori risorse ma poi
abbiamo capito che questa non era la
strada giusta
fare di più con meno generalmente
risulta demotivante per l'organizzazione
e a parte i casi di inefficienze
evidenti risulta avere anche un
beneficio marginale i manager infatti
che si trovano costretti a diluire il
loro budget su una serie di attività che
ritengono importanti tendono ad assumere
un comportamento funzionale un
comportamento difensivo oltre a sentirsi
parte passiva del processo
noi invece abbiamo deciso di fare meno
con meno ma in modo da generare un
impatto superiore
ecco la vera sfida è riuscire a capire
intima cosa la fine farà la differenza
tra il successo e la normalità
proprio le riflessioni sul ritorno in
work ci hanno fatto mettere in
discussioni partendo dalla formula ogni
singolo momento ogni singola energia
profusa all'interno della giornata
lavorativa
calcolando come questa fosse funzionale
alla crescita del business e in caso
contrario
l'abbiamo eliminata non vi nascondo che
questo approccio ha avuto un grosso
successo all'interno dell'organizzazione
ha scatenato un'energia positiva un
effetto quasi liberatorio
in effetti analizzare le singole
attività lavorative o le attività che
noi facciamo all'interno di una giornata
non dal punto di vista della loro
importanza ma dal punto di vista della
loro essenzialità porta a vedere le cose
da un punto di vista completamente
diverso e ad essere molto più selettivi
e molto più esigenti soprattutto con se
stessi ea dover scegliere
abbiamo così rimesso anche in
discussione il concetto di strategia
spesso nelle aziende si confonde la
strategia con i numeri con il darsi
degli obiettivi sfidanti
noi invece abbiamo mandato maturato la
consapevolezza che strategia significa
dire di no oggi la vera sfida non è cosa
fare oggi la vera sfida è cosa eliminare
tra tutto quello che noi consideriamo
importante ma che alla fine non farà la
differenza
attenzione non si tratta di fare una
lista delle attività in ordine di
importanza
si tratta di capire tra tutto quello che
è importante cosa la fine avrà veramente
un impatto materiale sui risultati e
sull'organizzazione e coraggiosamente
eliminare tutto il resto
solo così avremo il tempo per
concentrarci su quello che veramente
conta e aumentare la nostra probabilità
di successo fare di più aggiungere è
relativamente semplice fare di meno
eliminare semplificare è molto più
complicato perché perché bisogna
scegliere
discutere in in azienda non solo di
numeri di risultati di obiettivi ma
senza imbarazzi anche di altre tematiche
come la felicità come le energie profuse
apre gli occhi sull'impatto che il
nostro atteggiamento a sull'efficacia
dei rapporti proprio le discussioni sul
tempo ci hanno portato a far attenzione
a non occupare inutilmente il tempo
degli altri quante volte ci siamo
trovati in una riunione in una
situazione e dopo un po di tempo abbiamo
capito che stavamo buttando via il
nostro tempo
beh che diciamo che soprattutto in
azienda non è sempre possibile decidere
a cosa dedicare il proprio tempo ma
qualcosa la possiamo fare possiamo
evitare di trascinare colleghi ma anche
nella vita privata amici parenti in
situazioni similari
ecco diffondere in vda e rispetto e la
cultura del valore del tempo altrui ha
raccolto sicuramente un enorme successo
già nel 1958 circa 60 anni fa parkinson
con la sua legge postulava il lavoro si
espande fino ad occupare tutto il tempo
a disposizione più tempo si avrà più se
ne sprecherà
e quindi abbiamo messo un po in
discussione tutto il tempo che
trascorrevamo insieme in azienda abbiamo
cominciato con ridurre le riunioni del
50 per cento
abbiamo cominciato con eliminare tutte
quelle riunioni che non erano
direttamente collegate ad una priorità
ritenuta essenziale per la crescita del
business e poi abbiamo abolito tutte le
presentazioni più lunga di una pagina
quei lunghi noiosissimi presentazioni in
power point che generalmente hanno lo
scopo di supportare chi presenta e
lasciatemi dire anche di gratificare chi
presenta ed renano energia tutti coloro
che purtroppo sono costretti ad
ascoltare
così facendo abbiamo liberato del tempo
per la discussione e per guardarci negli
occhi e per connettere ecco la
connessione guardare una presentazione
fissare uno schermo crea informazione
discutere guardandosi negli occhi crea
connessione essere connessi significa
avere piena consapevolezza dei pensieri
delle emozioni e dello stato d'animo
delle persone che ci sono di fronte solo
essendo connessi si riesce sta pur aree
una conversazione efficace attenzione
che la vera connessione richiede impegno
sappiamo che ben poco possiamo fare per
migliorare il nostro quoziente
intellettivo
infatti questo si forma nei primi anni
della nostra vita di in parte congenito
ma molto possiamo fare per migliorare
quello emotivo
durante tutto l'arco della nostra vita
questa è una buona notizia
chiaramente bisogna mettere
l'allenamento sull'intelligenza emotiva
in cima alla lista
e poi bisogna togliersi dal centro
bisogna chiedere feedback ascoltare
senza pregiudizi e sperimentare
ecco questo è un esercizio che abbiamo
fatto insieme in azienda
e c'è un antico proverbio che recita se
vuoi andare veloce rallenta quindi
dedicare del tempo alla connessione
prima che innalziamo una discussione o
con una persona o all'interno di una
riunione in azienda risulta estremamente
efficace e ha contribuito a creare un
ambiente di lavoro molto più piacevole
ogni nostra parola ogni nostro
atteggiamento ogni nostro sguardo ha un
impatto sulle persone che sono lì con
noi avere questa piena consapevolezza
diventa fondamentale per un utilizzo
ottimale del tempo ma fare le scelte
giuste non è ancora abbastanza sono le
persone delle quali ci circondiamo e
soprattutto il contesto che creiamo
a fare la differenza ecco quindi
fermarsi un attimo per riflettere su
questi argomenti
diventa necessario diventa necessario
proprio per evitare di trascorrere
nostre giornate
come dicevo all'inizio rincorrendo
affannosamente
e per restare lucidi solo restando
lucidi si riesce ad essere efficaci con
noi stessi ma soprattutto con gli altri
ecco è la lucidità
l'ingrediente segreto senza il quale la
formula del return on work non torna e
quindi è importante fermarsi per
ricordarsi di respirare e dedicare del
tempo a noi stessi e agli altri come
vero stile di vita e di business e
ammirare tutta la bellezza che ogni
giorno appare nostri occhi e respirare
anche i profumi più delicati le persone
di successo stanno bene perché si
regalano del tempo e lo donano agli
altri sono le persone per le quali il
cuore batte per una ragione vera è la
leadership del dare oggi quella che
permette la perfetta sintonia tra
felicità e successo donare le nostre
risorse più preziose agli altri e come
donarla alla nostra felicità
d'altronde sappiamo bene che l'altruismo
e la prima forma di egoismo ma come
facciamo a restare lucidi se la cultura
umana ci porta a pensare che per fare
bene per avere successo bisogna fare di
più
ecco il ritorno work mi ha aiutato a
scegliere ea trovare il tempo da
dedicare a me e da dedicare agli altri
che la sera quando torno a casa e
appoggio la testa sul cuscino rivedo
tutti i fotogrammi della giornata e
tutti quei momenti in cui sono riuscito
a respirare ea connettere ea dedicare il
mio tempo agli altri
penso che la bellezza della vita sta nel
dare e nel condividere e mi addormento
felice
ecco per per chiudere questo momento non
posso che augurarvi tempo non un dono
qualunque come scriveva e limitless in
una sua poesia tempo non solo per
trascorrerlo ma perché ve ne resti tempo
non solo per guardarla all'orologio
ma per toccare le stelle tempo per
trovare voi stessi tempo per la vita
grazie per il tempo che oggi avete
deciso di donarmi
[Applauso]